on connaissait tous les lycées ou pas si
je vous dis attendez je vous donne à
vous le voudrez vous ne souffrez pas le
ministre de l'éducation est lé daily
mercredi
bah merci au rayon dans l'âme c'est fini
de lui donner past et bars en payons
vous le ministre de l'agriculture le
foll
enfin bien sûr le drian ses ministres de
quoi désormais vous ministre de
l'intérieur facile à manuel valls ou non
c'est plus lui matin ça va durer je suis
sûr que ça on va se plante
gérard comme ça tu as composé du adore
pas du tout pas dur je voudrais vous
pose un anormal riz thoirette ministre
de l'outre-mer pourquoi c'est important
le thon vert mais c'est vrai que c'est
qu'ils ministre de l'outre-mer victorien
lurel bas bien sûr
[Applaudissements]